bien nos hemos quedado en el problema
número 12 así que vamos a hacerlo el
problema número 12 y dice sí acá es un
entero positivo ok que es entero entero
positivo positivo cuál es el valor
mínimo que puede tomar cam de tal manera
que me tengo a lo siguiente la siguiente
expresión la raíz cuadrada de 5 k entre
3 de tal manera que esto sea un entero
yo quiero que esto de aquí sea un entero
si acaso un entero positivo y no sólo
eso esto es buscar nos la caja que tenga
un valor mínimo que logra hacer esto y
bueno hay varias formas de resolver el
problema pero se me ocurre que la forma
más fácil es a ponerle nombre a esta
expresión que tengo aquí voy a ponerle n
y voy a decir que n es a esta expresión
que tengo aquí voy a decir que en esta
expresión que tengo aquí pero no sólo
eso voy a decir que es un entero lo que
estoy buscando es que esta expresión sea
un número entero por lo tanto voy a
decir que n es un número entero y si de
aquí lo que quiero obtener es el valor
de acá que cumpla
que esto se haga mínimo pues qué te
parece si de aquí despejó acá vamos a
ver que el valor podrá tomar cam para
que esta expresión sea a un entero y si
quieres pero acá nos va a quedar que a
de aquí voy a elevar al cuadrado ambos
lados de esta ecuación voy a llevar al
cuadrado esto y al cuadrado esto de aquí
me va a quedar que n cuadrada es igual a
5 cam entre 3 de aquí puedo multiplicar
ambas partes de esta ecuación por 3 nos
va a quedar que 3 en el cuadrado es
igual de 5 camps o dicho otra manera si
de aquí ha vivido todo entre 5 me va a
quedar que 3 entre 5 por n cuadrada esto
es igual a acá ok estoy despejando acá
porque es lo que quiero ver es cuál es
el valor mínimo que puede tomar n de tal
manera que puede ser un número entero y
como yo sé que es un número entero pues
vamos a variar aquí los números enteros
de tal manera que me den un número cam
un número que sea entero y positivo
entonces n va a ser un entero positivo
también es lo padre del asunto como en
el caso entre los positivos
ahora lo que voy a hacer es variará en
voy a variar esta n de clean para ver
qué valor puede obtener para acá y qué
pasa si anna vale 1 bueno si me vale 1
no quedaría am 3 por 1 3 por 1 entre 5 a
lo cual es tres quintos y tres quintos
no es un número entero por lo tanto en
igual a 1 no me serviría si n vale 2
date cuenta que va a pasar lo mismo
de hecho date cuenta que el problema es
que tenemos que dividir entre 5 y que el
número elevado al cuadrado
que número entero elevado al cuadrado es
difícil entre 5 bueno en igualados no es
la respuesta 4 por 3 2 entre 5 a no es
un número entero en igual a 3 tampoco en
igualdad 3 pasaría lo mismo porque
tendría
27 en 35 lo cual nos número entero en
igual a 4 pasa lo mismo y en e igual a 5
en igual a 5 si va a ser división entre
5 porque tengo 5 como factor 5 por 5 25
25 por 3 entre 5 cuantos eso vamos a
ponerlo aquí 25 por 3 entre 5 bueno pues
esto es lo mismo que es lo puedo
cancelar con este me queda 5 esto es lo
mismo que 3 x 5 lo cual es 15 15 es el
valor más pequeño que puede tomar camps
camps es decir camps igual a 15 es el
valor más pequeño que puede tomar acá de
tal manera que esta expresión de aquí
sea un entero y fíjate bien de hecho si
nosotros ponemos acá aquí como 15 vamos
a obtener un número entero 5 por 15
entre 315 entre 13 5 por 5 225 en la
raíz cuadrada de 25 es precisamente 5 y
bueno puedo asegurar que este es el
mínimo
el mínimo porque probamos para en los
primeros valores posibles
de enteros positivos entonces nos dimos
cuenta que el mínimo tenía que ser
cuando n vale 5 y es cuando acá vale 15
ok problema número 12 vamos el problema
número 13
a un problema número 13 y me dice lo
siguiente las tres figuras siguientes y
las voy a poner justo aquí a las tres
figuras siguientes
tengo una figura parecida a ésta una
figura parecida a ésta cuyo lado vale
uno es un pequeño cuadradito después
tengo una cruz
tengo una cruz parecida a ésta algo así
y algo así y algo así y algo así algo
así
algo así algo así algo así algo así algo
así después se unen estos dos cuyos
lados 11
1 ok y por último tengo una pieza
parecida a ésta tengo algo así algo así
ok algo así algo así y después aquí baja
y después
sube sube algo así de tal manera que
este lado vale 2 y este lado vale 1 ok
esto también vale 1
ok a mí me dice las tres figuras
siguientes representan piezas de cartón
realmente esto de aquí son piezas de
cartón todos los ángulos de cada una de
las piezas es de 90 grados todos los
ángulos se forman con 90 grados todos
los lados cortos valen 1 todos lados
cortos valentino y los largos valen 2
cuales las siguientes figuras se puede
formar a uniendo las tres piezas de
cartón aunque vamos a fijarnos en las
figuras en las opciones la primera
figura
se ve más o menos así tengo algo por
aquí tengo algo por acá baja después
esto va así después esto va así
ok y después aquí tengo algo así sube y
después se une con esto y me dicen que
este valor es 3 ok y que este valor es
uno ok esto también vale 1 muy bien
entonces habrá forma de poner estas tres
figuras aquí sobrepuestas pues vamos a
ver primero muy bien fijar la figura más
grande que es esta de aquí esta cruz
entonces vamos a poner esta cruz y si te
das cuenta la longitud que hay de aquí
hasta acá de esta cruz son tres unidades
es uno dos tres son tres unidades y
también tienen lo mismo de altura tres
unidades por lo tanto a no puede caber
aquí estás de acuerdo entonces le voy a
poner por acá imagínate que de aquí me
tomo una después sube como éste vale uno
este vale uno entonces va a subir hasta
acá arriba después va para acá otra
unidad después baja
y después otra vez lo para acá para
tomar este valor de 111 y después por
acá 111 esta cruz es esta misma cruz de
aquí si te das cuenta cada uno de sus
lados mide 11 11 111 y qué crees ahora
podríamos acomodar justo a este de aquí
estoy aquí que habría aquí a 111 este de
aquí o puede que haber aquí 111 o podría
caber aquí pero el problema lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que si éste
cabe aunque este que para éste ya no va
a caber en esta figura que tengo aquí en
esta representación que tengo aquí no
hay forma de acomodar esta pieza de
cartón y aquí bueno no hay forma de
acomodar la sin cortar la entonces a el
inciso 1 no es mi respuesta correcta
vamos a ver el inciso 2 el insisto 2
tiene una figura parecida a ésta déjame
hacerlo con cuidado por acá hubo cuatro
por la cas hubo cuatro ok
después para cada camino dos caminos dos
ok
después a bajo 2 bajo 2
más o menos así después para que el
camino uno para cada camino uno
si nuestros dos ok es más o menos así
después para acá abajo uno y cierro este
con este ok
cabra en esta spears aquí pues vamos a
ver primero de igual manera voy a
fijarme en la pieza más grande que es
esta pieza de kim y esta pieza de aquí
recuerda que tiene tres de largo y tres
de alto entonces
no voy a tomar esperando todos los
valores este vale cuatro este vale
cuatro este vale dos este vale 2 esteban
y este va a valer 2 ok entonces estos
dos valen 2 y vamos a ver si cabe esta
figura de aquí 7 figura caben entonces
tendremos que subir por acá aquí es la
mitad es 111 111
y entonces para cada también me movería
1 para que arriba hay que desplazarse
también uno hasta llegar aquí nos
movemos 1 subimos y ahora sí vamos para
acá y vamos para acá ok
parece ser que si cabe esta pieza de
aquí fíjate que de aquí hasta que tengo
un largo de 3 y tengo una altura de 3 ok
aquí ya puede acomodar esta de aquí esta
pequeña que mide 1 este cuadrado de 1 de
largo y lo voy a poner justo aquí este
cuadrado va a kim 111 que es justo este
de aquí
ok 1
11 y me falta esta pieza que vamos a ver
si ahora entra por aquí dice tengo dos
unidades
de base dos unidades de base a esto de
aquí vale dos que es justo esto de aquí
tengo 22 unidades de altura estas dos
unidades también son de altura
estas dos de aquí que por cierto son
estas dos de aquí así te das cuenta esto
mide dos porque si esto mide 4 activa 11
y está acá también vale 2 y después
puede darme cuenta que esto de aquí vale
1 esto de aquí vale 1 y tengo esta parte
de aquí
vamos a ponerle con este color que tengo
11 11 11 de lujo si cabe justo aquí 111
entonces esta pieza se puede acomodar
aquí y ésta
esta opción número 2 es correcta si yo
pongo estas piezas una encima de la otra
puede formar la figura número 2 ahora no
acabamos aquí vamos a ver si podemos
formar la figura número 3
que también está bien loca vamos a ver
si la puedo dibujar tengo de aquí hasta
acá 4 tengo 4 unidades después para acá
tengo una unidad bajo una unidad después
me muevo una unidad después bajo dos
unidades
ok y después lo muevo otra vez otra
unidad para acá otro para acá y 1 cierro
esta pieza de aquí ok
esto vale 4 1 1 para acá abajo 2
y 1 ok a ver fijémonos primero en la
pieza más grande y la pieza más grande
recuerda que tiene a tres y tres
entonces para acá si cabe porque son
cuatro y para acá tengo 12 32 3 entonces
la única forma de que me quepa esta
pieza aquí tendría que estar acá abajo
te das cuenta empezar por aquí empezar
por acá subir empezar por acá a subir
una unidad bajas y después tienes aquí
el otro brazo por así decirlo esta cruz
sin embargo si yo pongo aquí esta cruz y
me faltaría la parte de abajo qué pasa
con esta parte de abajo
aquí me quedaría un hueco que no existe
ok y por lo tanto pues en este este es
un número tres no es mi respuesta
correcta
me falta un espacio aquí para que yo
pueda acomodar a esta cruz y este
espacio no existe entonces no es mi
respuesta correcta
este es número 3 solamente me quedo con
el número 2 el número 2 si se cumple en
el número 2 puedo acomodar las tres
figuras posibles y bueno ya está el
inciso que me dice que solamente el 12
puede es el inciso c entonces ya está el
problema número 13 que estuvo bastante
entretenido porque me recordó a las
pistas de un rompecabezas o alegó qué sé
yo a problema número 13 14 problema
número 14 cuantos enteros mayores que 20
y menores que 30 se forman por la
multiplicación de exactamente dos
números diferentes que ambos sean primos
ok a cuántos entre los mayores que 20
menores que 30 vamos a poner todos los
enteros mayores que 20 y menores que 30
tengo 21 tengo 22 tengo 23
24 tengo 25 26 27 28 29 y el 30 no
porque tienen que ser menores que de 30
ok
cuántos de estos cuántos de estos se
forman por la multiplicación de
exactamente dos números diferentes que
están ambos primos y hay que tener
cuidado porque el uno no es un número
primo porque por ejemplo por aquí pero
algunos números primos ok vamos con
calma mejor 21-21 no puedo ver como la
representación como la multiplicación de
dos números diferentes y que ambos sean
primos pues si no 21 es lo mismo que 7
por 3 7 por 3 y 7 y 3 son primos por lo
tanto 21 lo puedo ver como la
multiplicación de dos números diferentes
y ambos primos 22 22 también 22
es lo mismo que 11 por 22 por 11 2 por
11 11 por 2
a 22 y qué crees a 2 es primo 11 es
primo por lo tanto este también me sirve
23 aquí está la trampa tú podrías pensar
buenos que 23 es lo mismo que 1 por 23
porque de hecho 23 es primo y el 23 es
primo pero en uno el uno no es primo
recuerda la definición de un número
primo un número primo saque el número
mayor o igual que dos que cumpla la
propiedad de que solamente es divisible
entre el mismo y la unidad es decir 1 y
1 recuerda que es un número tramposo por
lo tanto no es un número primo y ya está
no sería una de mis respuestas correctas
24 24 es lo mismo que 2 x a 12 o también
lo podemos ver como 3 por 8 pero si te
das cuenta cualquier par de números que
multiplicando se forma en 24 siempre va
a tener un número compuesto ya sea el 8
y hasta el 12 sea cual sea el número que
tú te quedas tomar y siempre va a haber
un número compuesto por lo tanto esta
tampoco es mi respuesta
correcta 25 25 5 x 5 y aquí estaría
perfecto tenemos dos números ambos
primos pero no son diferentes por lo
tanto en 5 por 5 no me funciona esta no
es parte de mi respuesta 26 es a dos por
tres en dos por 13 y 13 y dos números
primos por lo tanto estos si me
funcionan 27 27 es 9 por 3 9 por 3 pero
date cuenta que tres es número primo
pero 9 es un número compuesto recuerda
que el 9 es tres por tres y por lo tanto
27 no me funciona 28 es 2 por 14 pero
aquí pasa lo mismo que con el 24
cualquier par de números que nosotros
tomemos que su multiplicación forme al
28 siempre va a tener un número
compuesto por lo tanto esto no puede ser
una respuesta correcta 28 de hecho
también es lo mismo que 7 por 4 7 por 4
pero aquí tengo el número compuesto y no
me funciona y 29-29 es un número primo
por lo tanto solamente se puede escribir
como 1 por 29
9 es primo pero uno no lo mismo que aquí
con el 23 y por lo tanto tampoco es mi
respuesta correcta así que solamente
tengo 3 21 22 y 26 123 a que es el
inciso b solamente existen 3 enteros
mayores de 20 en menores que 30 que
cumplan esta propiedad programa número
14 vamos al problema número 15 y último
así que vamos a meterle velocidad tengo
un triángulo rectángulo estamos en el
problema número 15 tengo un triángulo
rectángulo parecido a este esto no
parece tenemos los rectángulos y que
vamos a completarlo ok
de tal manera que uno esto es el
problema número 15 2 este la hipotenusa
valga 10 unidades este lado vale 7 menos
x y este lado vale 7 más x
y lo que me preguntan es cuánto valen a
cuánto es equivalente 49 más x cuadrada
ok y para obtener en esta expresión de
kim voy a utilizar el teorema de
pitágoras así que vamos a trabajar con
el teorema de pitágoras que nos dicen
si nosotros tomamos un catéter de bala
al cuadrado
7 - x elevado al cuadrado ya esto le
sumamos el otro cateto elevado al
cuadrado 7 + x + x mas x esto elevado al
cuadrado esto debe de ser igual a la
hipotenusa elevado al cuadrado es decir
a 10 elevado al cuadrado pues vamos a
desarrollar estos binomios el cuadrado
perfecto me queda 49 menos dos veces el
primero por el segundo aquí es 2 por 7
14 por x 14 x 14 x
+ cuadrado del segundo más x cuadrada y
aquí tengo otro binomio al cuadrado
perfecto así que voy a desarrollarlo más
49 más dos veces primero por el segundo
14 x mas x cuadrada esto debe de ser
igual
perfecto ahora vamos a ver que se puede
cancelar de aquí porque de una manera
muy rápida puedo ver que éste y este se
cancelan y me queda solamente que 49 49
más x cuadrada más x cuadrada escuela
100 pero yo quiero saber cuánto vale 49
más x cuadrada así que para no complicar
más la vida aquí tengo 49 más 49 es
decir dos veces 49 y después tengo x
cuadrada más es cuadrada lo cual es lo
mismo que 2 veces x cuadrada
esto es igual a 100 y lo estoy
escribiendo de esta manera porque tras
lo que voy es esto entonces voy a
factorizar este 22 que me multiplica a
49 más x cuadrada esto debe de ser igual
a 100 o dicho de otra manera y ya que
está la respuesta a este problema 49 más
x cuadrada esto debe de ser igual a 50
si divido de ambos lados entre 2 y fue
justo por eso que yo puse este 2 aquí al
lado y después lo factor hice también
podría despejar el valor de xy sustituir
de aquí pero si eran mucho más tardado
así que prefiero darme cuenta de que
aquí está el patrón que yo estoy
buscando factorizar este 2 dividido
entre dos y ahora sin 49 más ex cuadrada
es igual a 50 acabamos el problema
número 15 ya no tengo tiempo y nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo